random sometime oh oh it's my move
uh-oh oh no am i losing and in one move
don't do it don't do it
I could abort I lost I lost me one move
I should have aborted I was the only way
to prevent meat Oh Gigi I'm so sad I
should just rage quit I'm debating
whether this would be like too extreme
click baits for YouTube I lost in one
move that's to click baby but maybe I
don't know good game actually was that
good I don't know
Paul's should be able to capture it when
they move two squares forward well I
guess we move on or no I can dream Pike
and rematch rematch
opponent doesn't want to rematch fair
enough
hey hey I got revenge ha ha okay now at
least our score is even no more
rematches decline okay I feel better
about myself now
I guess everyone was scared away after
that
that last debacle
winning in one move is it Alexa what
does scat mean as a verb scan is usually
defined as to go off hastily often used
in the imperative form or ask me to give
you more definitions for scan was that
hastily enough okay oh I'm playing
Hassan again this is the same person
right oh this is a tiebreaker salut each
one one game
now this is real chess random algorithm
Wow all right let's let's get you in
more revenge
good luck Hassan 89 ooh we have a Danish
or maybe a center game or maybe it could
be a coring let's accept it let's accept
the Danish gambit expecting Bishop c4
free pawns galore okay so I'm off two
pawns now the main theoretical line draw
play is d5 the idea is to give away both
pawns and then just have kind of an
equal onion and game yeah white has a
choice here so the main line is crazy
involving Bishop takes Knight f6 Bishop
f7 King f7 and I lose a clean but then I
wouldn't come back something something
oh I'm such a nice guy oh that's nice
your streams given me chill I don't know
what that means if you want to challenge
me you type exclamation point challenge
in the chat and then you click the link
if you're a sub you can connect your
meat just using just like what s up 72
did and then then it'll it should appear
purple here
oh thanks so much nuke nuclear Raven or
nuclear Raven sobbing it to your one so
when the pawn takes the line is a bit
less crazy I think it's just a matter of
developing and castle play rocky eights
Arvind 1995 thanks for solving with
Prime
usually when white plays a Danish though
like the whole idea is to have dangerous
bishops but now the the bishops are less
dangerous still up a pawn and Queen e7
and I think is a nice inclusion because
it's not so comfortable for white to
block the check yeah happy to see Bishop
e2
okay still gonna be a fights it's still
a matter of developing hey it's emo only
mood
there there is like a channel point
Redemption thing you can enable email me
mode also there's um
I did change the blindfold thing I have
my blindfold prepared you can I think I
think the cost is like fifty thousand
channel points this move
hmm
debating if I can get away with rook
rook e8 Bishop d3 takes
yeah I think it's okay if the bishop
moves anywhere I take anyone the pin
kind of helps out
have you played against some vichy have
I played fishy I don't think I played
wishy I took a picture of fishing I
could try and find it and this move
I think I've taken picture with like
most most top players let's see
whoa crazy move
so I mean we could trade Queens I think
I'm winning upon in multiple lines go
ahead and take okay
that's me it's low-grade Lobster thanks
for something
hey becoming a twitch baby you got the
baby badge so that baby badge I put the
most effort to into I drew that all by
myself in Photoshop wait
Oh opponent wants to win my bishop and
then me me if I take the knight I'm
going to take on f2
95 was a good Moodle it's all taken then
just move back
okay I found my son on picture hey look
it's me Anand yeah I was taken in 2015
the st. Louis chess club probably during
sync fell Cup as before the tournament
started we I was just visiting the club
with a friend
we were like touring the playing area
and Don was just kind of chillin there
ooh so if I take and then play Queen III
King F 194 I'm fighting means there's
Queen h4 in that line unfortunately ooh
but then g5 wait does might work this is
raining so if I go through this this is
very forcing there's no Bishop d4 I
think g5 just wins because the cool the
Queen's tie down to f/2 and the knight
is tied down to D 2 so if Knight takes
on on g5 then 92 is mate Queen can't
take on g5 is in lenguin the Queen and
then the knight also covers a square so
the Queen can't go to g3
there is one slight problem with this
line though I'm gonna do it it looks so
much fun I might regret this
I guess now White has to decide whether
or not to take it's actually interesting
Queen III King g3 which I just didn't
calculate at all and then that's a
question am i meeting 94 king g4 f5 King
jigs f5 Rock f8 King g4 f-14 h5 g 6o g 6
king h6 rookie tour mates ok King f1
also we don't go into any of that and
now I'm just up the exchange
ooh opponent wants to meet me but this
is horse meat
okay sweet revenge so now now a life
lifetime's score to 2-1 same same score
that I have against Carlson yeah just to
show this is kind of a D calculation I
don't think this is a great move
objectively so this is my original
calculation I'm threatening means Queen
h4 and g5 if my point got to this
position I think there's one move that
white can play to survive so all that
chat try and find its jack wait
yeah wait to move and try not to lose
yeah 9595 loses 292 means ooh are you
enticed
maybe I'm enticed or we're all enticed
thanks for the enticement bits bring him
yeah good job Ben God or been good
Bishop c1 and then if I move my queen
back then the Queen
maybe the line keeps going but I'm down
the piece and I'm not meaning oh wait a
minute
oh the knight can take here so let's
check this with engine oh I can take on
e 2 or F 3 Oh so this is still better
for luck Oh Bishop c4 anyone say Bishop
c4 so I was wrong I also thought Bishop
c1 was the best move but apparently
Bishop c4
the idea being I can't give away my
queen for the rook because White's going
to take back and if I go for this line
then my Knights attacked and
it's complicated oh but I have 92 it's
just a really complex position but
there's no reason to go for a bishop
bishop f2 in the first place anyway um
yeah if you guys want allies this is uh
this game is the most recent game on me
chests I played